wo ist die mysteriöse dunkle materie
woraus besteht sie fachleute sind ihr
jetzt im halo unserer galaxie der
milchstraße auf der spur
es ist ein völlig neuer blick in den
äußeren bereich der milchstraße de-mail
und auf der basis von daten der nasa und
esa denn mit hilfe der neuen karte des
äußeren halos unserer galaxie könnten
wir endlich der dunklen materie auf die
spur kommen handelt es sich bei diesem
bereich sogar um den speicher der
dunklen materie klicks um science im
future geht es dreimal pro woche
spannendes science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen mit dem griff halo
meinen fachleute das was sich rings um
die scheibe die meist als eigentliche
galaxie betrachtet wird befindet es
handelt sich um eine an ernst fehr ische
also kugelförmige region in der
kugelsternhaufen und stern ströme ihren
platz haben genauso wie eine menge an
gas plasma und vielleicht eben auch die
mysteriöse dunkle materie ist im halo
von galaxien zu finden als das gehört
also zum sogenannten gravitative
einzugsgebiet einer galaxie und das
alles ist nicht ohne denn die
gravitations wirkung der dunkle materie
im halo hat großen einfluss auf das
verhalten der gesamten galaxie der
innere bereich des milchstraßen halos
konnte in der vergangenheit schon
ziemlich gut erforscht werden ganz
anders sieht es dagegen mit dem
außenbereich aus dieser ist mehr als 200
tausend lichtjahre vom galaktischen
zentrum entfernt doch genau dort
erhoffen sich wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler spannende erkenntnisse
beispielsweise hinweise auf die
wechselwirkung und sagen galaxie mit
namen nachbarn nun gelangt eine
spektakuläre premiere in diesem
zusammenhang dass us forschungsteam vom
harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics konnte eine neue karte des
äußeren milchstraßen halos erstellen auf
grundlage der daten des nasa teleskops
weiß und des esa-satelliten gelang es
ihnen die entfernung und bewegung von
1.300 massereichen sternen aus dem halo
zu ermitteln durch diese aufwenden
der analyse offenbarten die fachleute
somit verschiedene zonen stellare
ansammlung bis in eine entfernung von
achtung 325.000 lichtjahren vom
galaktischen zentrum entfernt genau in
dieser region vermutet man nochmal
achtung eine gigantischen speicher für
dunkle materie dunkle materie in aller
munde doch trotz intensiver forschung
hat sie noch nie jemand gesehen oder
gefunden es ist lediglich eine hypothese
also eine annahme vorstellen kann man
sich die dunkle materie vielleicht als
sehr feinen und nicht sichtbaren nebel
der zwischen den stern umher rabatt oder
es sind eben schwarze löcher von denen
ja immer mehr entdeckt werden aber im
fall der aktuellen studie gehen die
forschenden er von kleinen teilchen aus
obwohl sie nicht direkt sichtbar ist
macht sich dunkle materie indirekt eben
schon bemerkbar
und zwar durch ihre schwerkraft die
ganze galaxien um sich gruppiert und die
auseinander fliegen würden wenn es die
dunkle materie nicht gäbe
denn den gängigen theorien zufolge ist
dunkle materie also durch ihre wirkung
als eine art klebstoff dafür
verantwortlich dass wir überhaupt
existieren hält sie sich also im äußeren
halo der milchstraße versteckt kommen
wir nun durch die neue datierung endlich
auf die spur
bisher gab es immer eine große
herausforderung bei der erforschung der
milchstraße unserer position innerhalb
der spiralgalaxien dadurch ist es
äußerst kompliziert deren außenbereiche
genauer zu analysieren und genau das ist
der grund warum die ausdehnung des halo
und auch die zusammensetzung der
milchstraße bisher nur teilweise
erforscht ist immer wieder werden neue
studien veröffentlicht die überraschende
erkenntnisse über unsere heimat galaxien
offenbaren so konnte mit hilfe des
kontron teleskops erst vor kurzem
festgestellt werden dass der halo der
milchstraße wohl heißer und eisen ärmer
ist als bislang angenommen erst ende des
vergangenen jahres 2020 hatte ein
internationales forschungsteam eine
weitere spektakuläre entdeckung machen
können die fachleute hatten
herausgefunden dass sich der halo
unserer milchstraße und der halo der
andromeda-galaxie bereits überlappen
demnach erstreckt sich andromeda dass
halo 1,3 millionen
die arbeit in richtung der milchstraße
das entspricht rund der hälfte der
distanz zwischen den eigentlichen
galaxien zudem gehen die fachleute davon
aus dass auch für den milchstraßen halo
ähnliches gilt die einflusssphären der
beiden galaxien stoßen dieser studie
zufolge also bereits aufeinander im
klartext bedeutet das dass die kollision
oder aber verschmelzung von milchstraße
und andromeda galaxie bereits jetzt
begonnen hat darüber hat man ja
berichtet
für diese betrachtungsweise kommt es vor
allem darauf an wo man die außengrenzen
einer galaxie ansetzt und das ist eben
eine äußerst schwierige kiste denn im
gesamten kosmos ist eine grenzziehung
nicht sehr eindeutig um diese frage zu
klären hatte das internationale
forschungsteam das
hubble-weltraumteleskop zu hilfe
genommen und damit das uv spektrum von
43 fern quasaren analysiert deren licht
scheint durch den halo der andromeda
galaxie
hier ging es vor allem um die frage wie
groß und wie strukturiert dieser halo
ist dazu die beteiligte
wissenschaftlerin samantha barrick von
der yale university
die riesigen halos um galaxien zu
verstehen ist enorm wichtig denn diese
reservate enthalten den rohstoff für
künftige stern bildung in der galaxie
aber auch die ausströme vom vergangenen
ereignissen wie supernovae der halo ist
daher voller informationen über die
vergangenheit und zukunft einer galaxie
zudem verrät die ausdehnung des halo
einiges über die gravitative
einflusssphäre einer galaxie die messung
aus dem vergangenen jahr wegen
zweifelsfrei nahe dass der andromeda
halo deutlich größer ist als bislang
angenommen
den schätzungen der fachleute zufolge
könnten des weiteren im halo unserer
nachbargalaxien achtung rund 40
milliarden sonnenmassen an ionisiertes
gas enthalten sein
dieses ist offenbar aber alles andere
als gleichmäßig verteilt stattdessen
offenbart sich eine komplexe struktur
aus zwei ineinander liegenden schalen
auch zu der zusammensetzung konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mehr erfahren im inneren der schale
befinden sich schwerer elemente und das
gas ist weniger stark ionisiert dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam dies geht
wahrscheinlich auf die supernova
aktivität in der galaktischen scheibe
zurück die den inneren halo
direkt beeinflussen die bei den
sternenexplosionen aus geschleuderten
elemente werden bis in den inneren halo
geschleudert und prägen daher dessen
strömungen und zusammensetzung der
äußere teil des halo bewegt sich dagegen
einheitlicher ist ärmer an schweren
elementen heißer und stärker ionisiert
nach ansicht des forschungsteams erlaubt
dass möglicherweise auch rückschlüsse
auf den halo der milchstraße
basierend auf unseren ergebnissen ist es
wahrscheinlich dass die milchstraße
nicht nur eine ausgedehnte hülle aus
heißem gas besitzt sondern auch ein zug
kommt galaktisches medium aus warmem und
kaltem gas das ähnlich weit hinausreicht
wie bei einem domino
die neue studie offenbart jetzt zwei
aufwendige zonen im milchstraßen halo
zum einen eine diffuse große dichte an
sammlung in der nordhälfte dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam die über dichte im
norden überspannt fast ein viertel des
gesamten himmels das liegt nach ansicht
der fachleute an schwerkraft
wechselwirkung der milchstraße mit ihrem
nächsten nachbarn gemeint ist die große
magellansche wolke eine zwerggalaxien
die etwa 160 tausend lichtjahre von der
erde entfernt ist insgesamt kontinente
aktuellen studie rund 1300 riesensterne
identifiziert werden die sich hinter der
großen magellanschen wolke im
galaktischen halos häufen also in
unserem halo die gravitation der großen
magellanschen wolke erzeugt einen sog
und zieht eine spur von riesen sternen
zitat wie ein schiff im wasser hinter
sich her und die datenauswertung zeigt
eine weitere spannende erkenntnis denen
nach nähert sich die diffuse
zwerggalaxien unserer galaxie immer mehr
an vom galaktischen zentrum ist sie nur
noch 160 tausend lichtjahre entfernt
somit bewegt sie sich innerhalb des
milchstraßen halos also innerhalb
unserer galaxie quasi und beeinflusst
somit auch die gravitations balance der
milchstraße sprich diese galaxie
befindet sich bereits in unserer galaxie
die fusion hat begonnen
doch nicht nur das auch eine schweiz
förmige zone südlich der galaktischen
ebene wird von der großen magellanschen
wolke beeinflusst man kann sie sich wie
eine art kielwasser netzwerk galaxie
vorstellen die magellansche wolke bewegt
sich also durch den milchstraßen halo
und das hinterlässt spuren
zum einen sind es turbulenzen im plasma
und zum anderen aber auch in der dunklen
materie diese auffälligkeiten und
turbulenzen sind an den sternen ablesbar
das kann man sich vorstellen wie die
blätter in einem see
denn diese verraten ja die bewegung des
wassers und dieses kielwasser offenbar
tatsächlich spannende dinge denn die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind in der lage anhand der stärke form
und größe abzuleiten welcher bahn die
große magellansche wolke folgt und
welchen einfluss das auf die milchstraße
hat der aktuellen analyse zufolge muss
es sich bei den aktuellen geschehnissen
um die erste passage der zwerggalaxien
überhaupt handeln demnach wurde sie
möglicherweise erst vor wenigen hundert
millionen jahren zum begleiter der
milchstraße und ist gerade dabei unsere
galaxie das erste mal zu umkreisen dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam der jetzt
beobachtete sehr starke lokale schweiz
belegt dass die magellanschen wolken
noch bei ihrer ersten passage um unsere
galaxie sind denn wenn die wolken schon
mehr als einen kompletten orbit um die
milchstraße hinter sich hätten wäre der
schweiz schwächer und vielleicht gar
nicht mehr deckt ihr bar
die neue karte der äußeren milchstraße
könnte zudem auch spannende hinweise ist
auf die natur der dunklen materie
liefern auch hier wieder im fokus die
schweiz förmige kiel welle der
magellanschen wolke diese spur und vor
allem deren stärke und form könnten
tatsächlich die eigenschaften
beschaffenheit und verhalten der
mysteriöse dunkle materie offenbaren
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam das ist
ähnlich wie bei der quelle eines boots
die sich verändert wenn man durch hohe
nie statt wasser fahren würde weil die
quelle von der gesamten schwerkraft
geprägt wird und nicht nur der der
sichtbaren sterne ist ihre existenz und
morphologie ein stringenter test für die
nicht standard modelle wie fassen sagt
matter oder selbst interagierende dunkle
materie und auch für alternative modelle
der gravitation die fachleute gehen
davon aus dass die interaktion zwischen
der großen magellanschen wolke und der
dunkle materie enormen einfluss auf
unsere heimat galaxie hat die große
magellansche wolke wird demnach von der
dunkle materie in ihrer geschwindigkeit
gedrosselt das führt dazu dass sie
ordnet immer kleiner wird also sie in
immer engeren kreisen um unsere
milchstraße sich bewegt die folge davon
eine kollision zwischen milchstraße und
der zwerg galaxie laut der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
müssen wir möglicherweise in etwa zwei
milliarden jahren mit diesem ereignis
rechnen doch noch ist das forschungsteam
dabei die neue karte und die daten die
dahinter stecken mit anderen modellen
und beobachtungen zu vergleichen und
genauer zu analysieren kollision unserer
milchstraße mit der andromeda galaxie
hat begonnen sehr spannendes video also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal klicks um science and
future ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran